well shows reopening fans of the nascar
races over the weekend golden knights
fans have
games have fans as well college hoops
are now in town all signs of normality
returning to las vegas from those
pandemic shutdowns
hector mejia live this morning on the
las vegas strip with a look at the
events helping turn things around hector
good morning
hey there john good morning and it was
one year ago this week when events
conventions and shows here on the las
vegas strip began to shut down and here
we are
52 weeks later special events are coming
back to town
this week five ncaa conferences have
their basketball tournaments in las
vegas
that includes wcc and whack at the
orleans arena the big west at mandalay
bays michelob ultra arena
plus the mountain west at thomas and
mack and the pac-12 tournament at
t-mobile arena
though none of the games will have fans
in the stands this week many of those
same teams
were here last year when college
basketball made the unfortunate decision
to cancel
post season play this past weekend
resorts kicked off pool season
some nightclubs and day clubs reopened
and thousands of racing fans came to
town for nascar
visitors we talked with were split on
whether they see this as
quote unquote getting back to normal
as far as us walking around i think
that's fine getting to
you know the fresh air but other than
that no i don't think we should be
getting in the pool
and going to nightclubs together that's
too close
a lot of mixed reaction about this and
coming up in the weeks ahead we have st
patrick's day did not happen last year
the start of the end of
ncaa basketball tournament and spring
break all of which are expected to draw
crowds large crowds which we have not
seen in recent months and also one week
from today on march 15
businesses here across the valley can go
back to 50 percent capacity
and some outdoor gatherings will change
from 250 people
up to half of the venue's capacity so a
lot to look forward to here
in terms of reopening reporting live
this morning hector mejia
8 news now